Um, okay.
I am here for this dress. It is two separate pieces.
Very, very nice material.
It's supposed to be kind of shape worry,
so it does kind of clench you in.
It is very, very,
very soft. I need to bug my husband to take me on a date night
because I need somewhere to wear this now.
Absolutely love it. Absolutely obsessed.
They usually will do coupons in the TikTok shop,
so go check, see if you have any coupons before you buy one of these.
I think they have it in black, too,
and a few other colors, but I definitely want it in black.
I think it's so pretty, so flattering.
I feel like it would look good on so many different body types.
So go check it out.